Well, I'm sure nothing would happen
between a wolf and a rabbit.
Especially Legoshi.
Are you nervous? Just relax.
It's my first time, too, with a carnivore.
Is this a kind of greeting?
Your belly hair's the same color
as your face.
This is how small animals greet
each other?
Such a beautiful cream color.
I want to know...
where it leads to.
What?
I need you to be cooperative
to create a romantic atmosphere.
Isn't that what you came here for?
-What do you mean?
-I'm saying...
Oh, gosh.
Did I jump to conclusions?
But still, he refuses after
-I took off his belt?
-You'll catch a cold.
You may also get bug bites.
You should get dressed.
I'm going back.
Sorry to bother you!
He's gone.
So he really didn't come here for that.
I feel guilty.
Of course he'd run away.
Wait, really?
How come a big carnivore like him
would want to run away?
He was seduced
and all he did was to cover me up?
That's ridiculous.
What a weirdo.
What was that?
What just happened to me?
Legoshi.
I'm sorry about that.
I was waiting for you to return.
Hey, why did you leave--
Anyway, nothing happened to you?
Nothing in particular.
-What should we do?
-Let me see.
I see. I'm relieved.
You were running down the stairs
four at a time,
so I thought you were in a fix.
What do you mean by... a fix?
There's a buzz among the herbivores
about that rabbit.
Apparently, she's sleeping around
with so many males.
I mean, that's a slut.
Can you believe it? She looks so innocent.
I guess even she couldn't do anything
to a wolf, though.
So, did you get roses?
Flowers...
She said she tends flowers thoroughly
as if they're her children.
I'll talk to everyone and scratch the plan
of getting roses from the garden.
You might be hearing
a lot of things about her,
but I think she's nice.
What a weirdo.